bon ça y est les soldes d'été ont
commencé comme chaque année vous vous
êtes tombé sur vos articles préférés
[Applaudissements]
merci pour faire prêter le moment de
faire des bonnes affaires pour les
enseignes c'est aussi l'occasion de
remplir les caisses depuis la
réouverture les performances sont plutôt
sont plutôt bonnes voire très bonnes et
les méthodes sont parfois subtiles alors
gare aux arnaques pour entre les prix de
référence parfois augmenter délai du
sceau pas toujours appliquée et des
articles ni remboursé ni échangé il faut
bien se rencarder avant de flasher sur
n'importe quel prix un premier prix de
17 euros 50 a été camouflés et remplacé
par un autre prix de 25 euros
heureusement ce soir on va vous donner
toutes les meilleures affaires sans se
faire avoir dans notre dos de l'été
alors que chaque année maintenant il des
sommes quasiment tous les trois mois il
y avait c'était un peu un événement
matin il a tout le temps black friday on
sait plus très bien comment faire
est-ce que les arnaques dans le domaine
des soldes sont monnaie courante
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous dire oui
oui complètement d'accord dos et c'est
en fait l'île le sol s'est mis en place
maintenant pour berner le consommateur
j'ai envie de vous dire que dès le
départ on va partir d'une base c'est que
la solde est assimilée quelque part à
l'opportunité et dans l'inconscient
collectif le marketing notre éducation
et puis même les médias font en sorte
qu' on a un ancrage qui a été créé dès
le départ justement pour sédater notre
cerveau et partir de ce principe que de
toute façon on va avoir le droit à une
opportunité donc c'est le moment où le
consommateur est encore plus vulnérables
bah oui à partir du moment où ils
arrivent en fait c'est comme s'il était
en état d'hypnose ils arrivent ils
pensent que de toute façon il va avoir
une réduction alors que c'est pas
forcément le cas alors quand on arrive
au magasin on voit moins 40 oui il
paraît que le prix en fait c'est pas du
tout - 40 en dessous ils ont mis un prix
fictif en fait seront peints au même
prix ça c'est totalement interdit par la
loi
cc by courante bah ça arrive si je dis
pas que c'est monnaie courante mais ça
arrive l'idée c'est quand même de partir
du principe que on va dire que larnack
risque reste l'exception à la base est
bon on a quand même des personnes qui
sont fiables tout à fait fiable et qui
sont vraiment là pour faire du business
de manière tout à fait correct mais il
faut rester attentif et vigilant quand
vous nous on se balade dans la rue comme
on peut reconnaître une boutique et un
peu suspecte alors déjà l'idée c'est
quand même de rester vigilant on peut
commencer par faire barmes des repérages
un peu comme tout à chacun alors moi je
ne sais pas comment vous faites mais en
général je vais regarder un petit peu ce
qui m'intéresse je fais des études
comparatives en fonction de ce dont j'ai
besoin de ce que je recherche et puis
après quand je rentre à l'intérieur je
regarde un petit peu ce qui est annoncé
l'otan
j'ai envie de te dire tu regardes tu as
tarifs qui on peut situer
tu fais ta ta des moments tu arrives tu
regardes un peu sur internet j'ai pas ce
que tu fais toi le fort bon bah moi plus
que de regarder la télé plutôt que de me
faire marcher je regarde un petit peu tu
vois ça m'intéresse forcément je me
renseigne et puis et puis ensuite et ben
qu'est ce que je fais quand je rentre
dans un magasin je vois loin 70% je
demande à la vendeuse parce que je vois
que du 50% qu'est-ce que je écouter vous
pourriez mandic est un petit peu aussi
parce que manifestement il y avait des
choses qui étaient annoncés de base
voilà je regarde des étiquettes
également je fais des études
comparatives je regarde soulève aussi
des équipes t2100 c'est sûr voilà alors
ça souvent des mauvais soirs c'est pas
ça s'est passé le sas est une méthode
c'est augmenter le prix de référence de
référence car tout à sa
gueule c'est pas grave de faire ça si
c'est interdit
sa garde et alors ci dessus
je veux dans mon magasin
je soulève une étiquette et je vois que
en fait c'est une arnaque qu'est-ce que
je peux faire concrètement alors moi
très concrètement la première la
première chose que je vais faire je vais
aller voir gentiment la vendeuse fixe
excusez-moi pouvez m'expliquer ne sont
qu il ya une petite incohérence je la
comprends coup pour une imbécile je vais
vraiment jouer les imbéciles c'est
benjamin issan affaire
je pense qu'on est on est on sait tout
faire quand on veut
quand on veut je lui demande et je vais
aussi prendre une photo 1 je vais pas me
gêner pour prendre une photo ou une
vidéo parce que si ça va un peu trop
loin en fonction des montants jeu fait
clairement pas me gêner pour faire des
négociations ce qu après c'est une
question de preuves pour pouvoir faire
des recours c'est comme à chaque fois et
puis bon je vais lui demander un petit
peu ce qu'ils ont et pire exemple
obtenir une vraie réduction du coût
quand on met le doigt sur une forte
réduction alors normalement oui d'un
point de vue légal sauf que entre le
droit et les usages une fois que vous
avez un gamin alors il ya une caméra
cachée qui illustre assez bien ce
phénomène de fausse fausses réductions
dès le 1er étage il s'arrête sur le
stand d'une marque qu'il vend lui aussi
cette année gagner
d'après cette vendeuse sur ce stand
certains vêtements en promotion ne
serait pas de toute première fraîcheur
arrière
selon cette vendeuse plutôt bavarde
le prix de référence de ce produit
aurait été gonflé pour ensuite être
baissé de 30% patrick n'en reviens pas
je
selon l'arrêté du 31 décembre 2008
article numéro deux le prix de référence
ne peut excéder le prix le plus bas
pratiqué dans le même établissement de
vente au cours des 30 derniers jours
donc ils peuvent anticiper des sols en
augmentant les prix ça ils peuvent le
faire dans la loi ca c 'est c'est une
chose pour le co la réduction qui
correspond pas à la réelle réduction
alors la réduction qui dresse toujours
alors le sol qui en fait ne correspond
pas au prix affiché ça ça arrive tout le
temps mais ça à réussir au sahel d'où
l'idée d'avoir la calculatrice sur sa
d'accord en tout cas moi c'est ce que je
suis je vous le dis tout de suite en je
prends ma calculette comme ça je suis
sûr de ne pas me faire avoir comme
l'autre arnaque aussi c'est qu'on n'a
pas le droit alors on doit vendre des
collections de l'année pas les
collections passées du moins du mois
passé à dire les anciens collection
essentiellement en fait les soldes ne
s'est pas coulé hier juste après aussi
quand on va au canton va fa les seuls on
voit pas non plus une très belle vie des
vitrines on dit tiens et le beau produit
n'est jamais serré soldes ça c'est quoi
c'est une partie commerciale
c'est un petit peu délicat pour le coup
si vous avez mis effectivement le la
réduction qui est juste affiché à côté
du produit on peut voir ça comme une
pratique commerciale trompeuse
effectivement après ça va vraiment être
du cas par cas c'est d'où l'intérêt de
prendre des photos ou des vidéos mona il
faut du matos on à rona
en regardons les présentoirs
où guillaume se rend compte qu'au milieu
des chaussures censé être soldées à -50%
il y en a qui ne sont soldées cas moins
c est comme ça qu il ya pas marqué
jusqu'à 50% ça sur mon pied que de 50%
sur la vie cette étagère
la commerçante va devoir être un peu
plus attentive sur la manière dont elle
range ses produits en rayon
[Musique]
elle encourt trois mille euros d'amendé
par infraction constatée
merci
et des cas comme celui là guillaume et
jérémy on rencontre beaucoup
en moyenne un commerçant sur quatre
oublie une étiquette ou place mal les
objets non soldés alors là en fait vous
voyez vous avez un produit donc une
ceinture
on avait donc qui indique à 25 euros
moins 30 % si vous regardez bien le prix
imprimé est à 17 50 autrement dit
guillaume se demande si le commerçant
n'a pas monter les prix juste avant les
soldes pour pouvoir afficher ensuite un
gros rabais ce qui est évidemment
totalement interdite alors
comme on peut toujours tomber sur un
vrai qu'à un vrai qu'un havrais prix
parce que la réponse peut avoir à chaque
fois globalement parce que ça c'est des
boutiques ou pignon sur rue tout à fait
par contre qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
bazire fait rage comme je vous accorde
quelque chose entre vous deux
mais les gens qui nous regardent et oui
la france parce qu'on se dit on
souhaitait avoir systématiquement fait
pas forcément systématiquement et abattu
mais si vous regardez un minimum l'idée
c'est d'avoir des repères de base comme
vous ça vous regarde et après les
étiquettes quand vous savez regarder les
étiquettes vous savez qu'il faut
regarder plusieurs enfants enfin
formation comme le prix de référence
vous regardez également la réduction qui
proposait donc moins 50 et ensuite le
prix que vous savez que derrière vous
pouvez regarder enfin soulever un petit
peu les informations que je voudrais
frier vous êtes d'une prise à temps
qu'est ce qui nous empêche de faire des
fausses étiquettes à mais là on est
d'accord là pour le coup mais là pour le
coup c'est la faute à pas de chance est
on est bien d'accord c'est compliqué
quand on vous dit qu'il faut regarder
bien les étiquettes pour vraiment bien à
garder regarder alice a eu le sentiment
d'avoir été abusés lorsqu'elle a regardé
de plus près ces achats de soldes elle
qui croyait avoir fait de bonnes
affaires découvre que certains prix
soldés correspondent plus ou moins au
prix d'origine du produit alors fraude
ou pas on était les voies et commerciaux
en caméra cachée pourquoi le prix et
pour celui ci est même pas pour les
chemins parce que ça dépend du produit
du palais qui déçoit tout comme ça et on
réussit tout pour le marché français
tout ça à chaque fois et pourquoi web
pour les produits et justement on n'a
pas d'explication les bonnes
explications si vous voulez c'est que il
ya des tarifs qui sont différents en
fonction des pays de destination puisque
niveau de vie et pas humainement c'est
un produit qui était vendu dans le
circuit espagnol il peut se retrouver
ensuite dans le circuit dans le circuit
national et pas forcément vendus au même
prix ce qui peut poser problème dans le
cas présent c'est que le consommateur va
se retrouver avec un prix soldés et 15
euros 99 et quand il va enlever
l'étiquette il va se retrouver en
dessous avec un prix avec un drapeau
espagnol à 12 euros 99 ce qui peut
l'induire en erreur sur la réalité ou
pas de la pratique de soldes par
l'entreprise dans lequel le produit a
été acheté en france alors est ce que
les grandes marques c'est un gage de
qualité pour les sols autrement dit si
on choisit fait pas passer des marques
mais voilà moi je crois qu'ils peuvent
pas se permettre de choses mais
j'imagine pas uniqlo annoncé un sol de
phobos dire
des coordonnées je vous explique la
télévision
[Rires]
se sont exprimés est-ce que tutoyer j p
et on peut aussi et quand on citer un
nom par hasard on peut dire h&m
donc est ce que c'est un gage de qualité
pour ne pas du tout on pourrait dire que
de base on pourrait avoir cette croyance
voilà mais cette croyance m'ont
franchement je vérifie à chaque fois
mais vous faites aussi des fois tu fais
comme moi je mets ma voix la havane
est
ce que tu fait de repérages oui oui si
c'est un mur alors à quel moment parce
que le soir donc préparation des soldes
n'ont qu'à ma télé et donc le repérage
pour éviter les arnaques à quel moment
mais en fait c'est même pas ça c'est que
moi quand je vais me balader j'ai
tendance à regarder un petit peu je suis
attentive et à ce genre de choses c'est
quelque chose qui me plaît que je rentre
dans un magasin je vais regarder ce type
d'information pareil je veux changer de
téléphone alors quand c'est sûr c'est
pour une petite robe à bandes rouges
vais pas m'amuser à regarder ce rayon
bien d'accord j'ai autre chose à faire
quand ça commence à chiffrer un peu plus
là je vais être attentif et je vais
faire des études comparatives je regarde
sur tels sites tels 6 j'en fais 2 3 je
vois qu'il ya une incohérence ou quand
je rentre quelques jeux rentrer dans le
magasin je vois qui est bon pour le coup
c'est assez compliqué puis je reviens je
retourne souvent dans le même type de
magasin aussi donc fini par connaître un
peu la vendeuse il ya aussi de nombreux
rebelles qui donne pleins d'informations
qui s'est quand même 80 % de la
communication quand je vois que la toute
l'équipe une réaction un peu suspecte je
commence à
en fait il faut se transformer en
sherlock holmes en fait pour mais pour
elle l' on amenait le quai alors ya une
nouveauté qui est apparue directement
désuet ça va aller c'est le black friday
or sa part avancé le das et la blague
couillonnades
on se perdait alors roulé dans la farine
regard des
véritables bons plans ou phénomène
marketing le black friday et ses
promotions alléchantes s'affiche
aujourd'hui partout c'est très bien
c'est une promotion
ça permet de profiter permet d'acheter
moins cher pour noël
les cadeaux affaire premier constat les
rabais importants sont limitées sur ses
vitrines cette parfumerie annonce
jusqu'à -50% mais dans le magasin seul
ce présentoir propose des réductions
aussi importante deuxième constat les
rabais les plus alléchants sont bien
souvent artificielle ce spécialiste va
nous le prouver on est sur un
distributeur donc il va vendre un
téléviseur à 699 euros 99 centimes on a
un tarif avec les frais de livraison à
720 euros si j'arrondis c'est à dire on
est exactement au même prix que ce qu'on
a observé aujourd'hui des promotions
pour le 'black friday' limité car en
france les ventes à perte ne sont
autorisés que pendant les périodes de
soldes alors vente à perte est ce que ça
existe ça les ventes à perte non je
pense pas honnêtement ah bon vous avez
un sacré moral à on est on est content
parce que et commentent sur dani donc
ton repérage de toi comme moi je
m'organise pour le black friday les
repérages donc ça serait par contre
baissé la journée avait mal
[Applaudissements]